so my first question is to launch
straight into it
this is based on true events they havend
can just ask what please introduce it it
just introduce ourselves and the film's
all the way down the line this is gonna
eat up some of my time
I'm Reed Van Dyck and I'm the writer
director of DeKalb Elementary
[Applause]
daran seal I'm the director of the
living o'clock Josh Lawson on the rise
of the I am Kevin Wilson jr. the writer
producer and director of my nephew
Emmitt hello Rachel Shenton the writer
and actress in the silent child hello
I'm the I'm Chris Overton and I'm the
director of this island child hello my
name is Katya Bennett and I am the
director of what to water to be as
whoreson I'm the producer of water water
okay first question for you guys okay
well how'd you come across this and my
one of my main questions really is about
the the research that you did and who
you managed to talk to you you know got
another question for you I it's based on
the film is based on an actual 9-1-1
call that made national news back in
2013 and i was doing research for a
feature i was writing at the time that
was also about a school shooting
incident and for that script i just
needed to know what a nine one one
dispatcher says when they pick up the
phone like what's the protocol what's
the first thing they say and so I
googled 9-1-1 call and this happened to
be the call the first call that popped
up and then in writing the film I was
able to get my hands on a good deal of
research there were court documents and
police reports as well as obviously the
transcript of the phone call interviews
of people who were there and then there
actually was security camera footage
without sound but footage from the
elementary school front office and then
also ask you about the casting of the
incredible cast in
that especially in the the intruder the
nothing isn't an actor or non-active can
you talk about the ather casting yes
sure they're both actors and I didn't
hold the proper casting I actually just
started watching lots of film and
television and anything that I thought
had people who would fit the the
character type and a lot of that was
actually just me you know scrolling
through the cast lists on IMDB of films
that I thought might have actors and so
he happened to be in a film called Palo
Alto that I knew had young people in it
and so I just was scrolling down the
IMDB page for that film and I saw his
headshot I thought well he looks
interesting and so I found that he'd
done some other work and tracked him
down in South Carolina and had him
audition over Skype and that was the
sister the same story for Tara who plays
Cassandra she lived in Mississippi
tracked her down and auditioned her over
Skype and did you manage to talk to any
of the real people involved at all
I I didn't talk to them during the the
making of the film and part I was made
the film as a student but said my
previous film it at UCLA and I was sort
of in awe of of Antoinette tough with
the stories based on and I'm not knowing
how the film would turn out I didn't
want to alert her too soon of what I was
up to hello boys all right through it
we've just got sort of a shorthand our
country you know straight to it doctor
is patient have this wonderful respect
for each other and now I'm we didn't
actually have to look very far for our
cast because they were we're all very
close friends and we have been for you
know a long time before that and I think
we one night we had dinner and we drank
a lot of wine and we're talking about
this idea which is Josh's stage play
which should be a stage play for many
years and yeah I was really interested
in it and the night I emailed him and
said we have to make
you know we have to we have to do this
together and so we found the time and
really it was just a sort of labor of
love between the groups and Diamond
Herman who's here and Jessica Raine were
in credited an past and amazing Karen
Bryson was producing it and so here was
something that did very very quickly
yeah congratulations on a very
depressing film and stage play so it
offers a play yeah so I was a am a big
fan of vaudeville of you know the
classic kind of double acts like Evelyn
Costello and and you know in Marx
Brothers and that sort of thing so I had
studied a lot of Ward ville when I was
at drama school and in doing that I was
just fascinated by the the mathematics
of it the the surgical nature of it the
precision that were that requires it's
sort of like a Sudoku puzzle that if 51
numbers off the whole thing doesn't add
up you know and so that was the that was
the fun and the challenge of the script
really and and if there's there was
another film in in the discussions we
had about the script I mean that in
itself was a who's on first
I mean you there's such a house of cards
that one you know the emphasis on the
wrong word in one moment would make the
whole thing topple over so it it's it
really was a dizzying development
process but the result is so satisfying
thing for us was for me very pleasing to
see an Australian film waver and is
dressed in very Australian contemporary
contemporary Australian clothes for
contemporary stating yeah just felt so
very today thank you thank you
we're flying the Aussie flag proudly and
also this short film that I was
nominated for was also based on a short
play that I did
[ __ ] that doesn't bug ya good luck mama
and voting's close buddies close late
[Laughter]
Kevin this you so again based on the
true story can you tell me a little bit
about how yeah a lot of people know the
story but you know how you came across
it and now you decided to turn this into
a song yeah when I was five years old my
mother showed me a photograph of Emmett
Till's corpse and it was pretty
horrifying and it stayed with me for
awhile
and she taught me about who he was and
how his death impacted the American
civil rights movement and when I got to
college and undergrad in Greensboro
North Carolina I wrote a play about it
just because it has stayed with me and
to that point and then finally when I
got to NYU I was grad film program it
was time to make another short film and
it was a story that was just kind of
burning inside of me and I just become a
father at the time and I was really
interested in the perspective of the
uncle who was his guardian at the moment
that he was abducted from his home and
the pain in having to decide whether to
allow your your own nephew to be taken
or to have your entire family killed so
I wanted to explore that and I wanted to
explore the strength that it took to
identify those mental camera because in
the context at that time in 1955 if you
were a black man accusing a white man of
anything you could be killed
so it took enormous strength and courage
for him to do that so those are the you
know that he the moments that I wanted
to focus on for the short and Spike
Lee's involvement yeah yes spike spike
is my professor my directing professor
NYU and I started taking the script to
him during my first year there
he and also Casey lemons who's a really
talented director as well is my
directing professor both of them sat
with me throughout the process of
developing the script and then giving me
notes on the on the final cut and then
spike gave me a lot of money for
post-production once he saw the film so
he helped me finish the movie and you
know I don't think would have would have
finished it in time without him I think
we're probably curious as what spikes
email or numbers future post-production
ventures that we go on I'm not in that
no it's a bit strange ok the cyma chart
Chris Rachel a since I've seen you in
the movie
again you'll see a little theme to my
questions about I know they don't but
love you Rachel to talk a bit about the
inspiration and yeah the inspiration
behind the movie and it's really close
to my heart actually my dad lived the
last two years of his life profoundly
deaf and I have huge involvement in the
deaf community and see the struggles
that deaf children and deaf people face
and because it's a silent disability
that you can't see and it's not
life-threatening
it goes it flies under everyone's radar
and I feel very passionately about
disabilities in film I think it's
something that I think disability under
represented in film and so that was
another impetus behind the movie but and
really it was the just the story in the
subject that urged me to put pen to
paper yeah and then Chris and I mean
both of you probably just in terms of
the casting and you know like how that
process went yeah ont costume was
something that was very important to us
and so yeah
we have to cast a profoundly deaf child
so we saw over a hundred kids with
varying levels of deafness and little
Maisie walks in and just blew us away
within 20 seconds and she was the only
child that came in whose first language
was sign language so it was just amazing
to see this tiny little thing just
moving her hands and I was just like wow
we were just blown away with it won't
wait so yeah
authentic Caston was really important to
us yeah watching the film have been
incredibly frustrated with everyone
around around their character and one of
my questions was it's not going to be
you know limitations sit bet it's not
not going to ask that nothing else that
I think well I just I mean maybe I will
maybe I will I don't know for me I feel
like there's I feel like you know people
have that preconception I think that is
the problem and I think there there is
lots and lots of misconceptions around
deafness around disabilities in general
but particularly around deafness but for
the reasons I mentioned before you can't
see it no one knows about its subject
that isn't talked about I felt very
passionately the story needs to be told
and and you mentioned the the parents
and I work a lot with the deaf community
and that's common that's super super
common and and parents of deaf children
they you know I was very passionate
about I didn't want them to be bad
people there are no there they're not
bad parents they're just sort of doing
the best that they can with the
situation they've got and limited
resources and limited education there
really isn't that much information out
there about this so really there isn't a
manual there's no go to nobody's
answering the questions from diagnosis
when it first happens newborn baby and
there really is no support they kind of
just go they they go off you go and you
know learn as you go along and access to
education for deaf children is terrible
they're all I think the problems are all
entirely avoidable it's just it's just
basically a lack of aware
in education and I think that films a
huge part of huge leap our for medium to
push our message say and you purposely
wrote it in mind with a middle-class
family because we purposely didn't want
to do it with a working-class family
because deafness doesn't discriminate
it's it's across all walks of life no
matter what background people are from
or you know if they're lucky in life
it's it kind of it's the same issues no
matter what thank you Katya
Tobias Tobias bonzer either you choose
[Music]
this incredibly challenging and you know
a very beautiful film again based on a
true story as you know talk about here's
original question talk about how the
inspiration came I came across the story
okay um so to be us grew up in South
Africa and he wanted to tell a story on
the African continent
from the beginning of our studies at the
Hamburg media school and during our
during the time we we were to pitch our
ideas for the graduation movies this
thing just happened and our principal
sent us a newspaper article and it was
like goose bumps in the first moment we
read it it was it was so important to
tell the story and it was um it was it
touched us so much and the message is so
strong and yeah it was just a story that
wanted to be told and we wanted to find
out if we would be the right one so we
went to Kenya for research tour and we
met the most amazing team one of them is
here and also her cinematographers over
there Christine and Felix could you
please also get your applause they are
yes so yeah we went to Kenya and tried
to find a a team and to research and it
yeah it became more and more important
to really tell the story well to be yes
Katya told me Kat you know you German
yes I'm just telling you that okay thank
you
how was the about filming with the I
don't know if there was a language
barrier or not but can you talk about
like yeah I mean Kenya everybody speaks
English and Swahili like those are the
two main languages so communication was
not a problem actually it's pretty
impressing because they have like 42
tribes is that you Christine yes and um
kids big like three languages at the age
of six I guess so they speak English
they speak Swahili and they speak their
tribe language so that's pretty
impressive so communication was not a
problem at all and we shot it in in soya
and Somali and the lines they're saying
there I think I know them now but I
worked very closely with a friend and
the casting director together we really
had the authenticity we needed so yeah
good okay
correct thank you correct answer okay
just quickly straight down the line
it's quickly talked about there you go
as I I don't I don't know it's all
pretty surreal and it's fun and it's
cool that now that the films get a
release and theatres and so that's been
very exciting it is surreal but we made
the I mean we've got the shortest short
I think I made would have made a little
longer if it was gonna get nominated but
I'm just I'm just excited that less
funny yeah
just better but I'm just excited that
the comedy and entertainment you know
you know we um we didn't expect it all
to obviously get to this point
and we're just we're we're just really
excited that yeah completely I can jump
on the back of that inside it you know
anyone who knows me knows that I bang
the comedy drama loudly and incessantly
and I think it is as valuable an artform
as anything and it is grossly
underrepresented often in award shows
like this so it took for us to be here
it is particularly sweet for me like
because I'm just such a student of
comedy I just adore it so you know we
are and I said that there are many times
just so grateful for the Academy for
recognizing the work and the artistry
that went into it into a comedy
so thanks yes very exciting I'm still a
student NYU right now and you know for
for show off
[Applause]
for us you know we never really expected
to get to this point but it's exciting
for us because we made this film because
we wanted to share the story of Emmet
with as many people as possible and
being nominated it gives us the
theatrical release and like read that's
for me the most exciting part because so
many more people folks back at home
where I'm from North Carolina I get to
watch it the way we intended it for it
to be seeing on a big screen so I'm
really grateful to be here and in case I
don't get to say this Sunday thank you
to the Academy
yeah it's just totally surprised yes
still and feels completely surreal the
subject obviously is it incredibly close
to me so and to have that in front of a
mainstream audience and for people to
see that it feels incredibly special I
also feel like it's definitely a year
for diversity and I think it's important
to remember that disability should be in
the diversity bracket as well so very
proud of that yeah
yeah by completely second that and it's
just so lovely to share it with our team
who are all out here like it's so
excited we've got our two producers and
one of our ideas stand up guys they're
awesome and they've been a huge part of
it so go for it it's not standing up
there we go so yeah for the message of
the film to have this platform and to
share it with a whole team is incredible
surreal isn't it the Oscars you know
I don't know if I know the right answer
but it's it's completely surreal for for
asar for me as well and the same time it
just opens the door for our movie and
its message to the world and it's like
so many people will see it and will
watch it and we'll know about those
amazing courageous people so that's just
the best and yeah you nominated to the
Oscars pretty cool we're gonna write for
that
I just love to say you know
congratulations to you all
as someone who was nominated in this
very category again his hammer at home
is someone who didn't win in this
category just so happy for you
so just won't be on asleep at night with
all the excitement that is just coursing
through my veins for all you people yeah
just on the cusp of success
whoever look it's not about who wins or
loses it's just about crashing the enemy
and and look you know I wish you all the
best and let's just hope that whoever
wins doesn't just like trip on the
stairs and break both our arms but dokey
voting is over again congratulations you
guys enjoy the rest of your evening
there's no moon
give it up all the all the shorts
tonight thank you and good night
[Applause]